so I've seen the entire series I want to
say congrats I'm not going to do any
spoilers today
um but before I get into it I always
like throwing a curveball at the
beginning which is for people that have
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why oh
[Music]
the first thing I'd like them watching
and why
um I did this short born in the
Maelstrom that just has like a little
special place to my heart and I have no
words it's just a voiceover but I don't
know I think it's maybe a nice little
like peek into
my type of performance like what I love
to do with performance which is like
facial expressions and body language and
all of that and that's how I choose to
communicate versus actual speaking
um so maybe that would be something that
I'd prefer to watch first jumping into
why I get to talk to you uh what was it
about this project that said oh I need
to do this there's just so many layers
to it um there's so many twists and
turns Mysteries I'm obsessed with that
kind of content psychological thrillers
there's also so many layers to each
character to each decision they make how
they choose to say something how they
respond to something and for me I felt
like I could put a lot of
uh care in like passion behind Ariana
and I really just I couldn't
see myself watching this and not being
in it
I had to do it yeah no completely I um
you this is not a spoiler but there's a
club scene and there's a cool runner
with you going in and um you know um can
you talk a little bit about filming that
scene and um and recreating that time
period that was the funnest part in
terms of the music being different and
and learning the kind of choreography of
it because it was such a specific kind
of
um movement and setting and it was also
one of the harder scenes I think we
filmed it over a couple of days
um and it was really intense but like
freeing and I don't know it was just
really
it felt like one of those moments and
you're like ah we're making like an art
piece kind of it's nice one of the
things about the series that I was
really impressed with um and it's not a
scene well what actually it is stuff
that you're in it is the I was like wait
uh is the beginning where it's in New
York City and outside Radio City and you
know basically taking over New York City
and recreating it for the time period
I'm like I was stunned by it because
that's like movie level production you
know but on TV can you sort of talk
about those sequences and recreating
that time period
um that is I had nothing to do with
recreating that so Props to the props
people and like the costume department
and all of that that is truly incredible
and but it's also kind of funny because
you know how like fashion kind of
repeats itself over time and we go back
and we bring things forward so it's like
I couldn't sometimes tell it's like are
you part of the crew or like are you
part of the cast members or like you
just a girl on the street with some like
great bell bottoms or something I don't
know so
it was kind of it was kind of fun to to
be like it was also chaotic so it was
just like whoa what a world but honestly
they did an incredible job of pulling
that off no it's it's movie quality like
I just couldn't believe the the scale
and scope of recreating all that in New
York City I mean that's not easy no not
at all so kudos to those guys
when you think about the shoot
um obviously there's gonna be days that
are tougher than others was there a day
you had circled in terms of oh this is
going to be a really challenging day
yeah then I think the there was a scene
where it's a conversation with me in uh
Ariana and Danny
um
in a diner and it just I guess the
contents of it
um
was one of those things where it's like
it's so important to the story and it's
so important to their characters but
it's also so
um I guess emotional or it like kind of
hit me personally and it's just one of
those things where you just want to do
it justice and you know you just kind of
keep amping yourself up for it and you
like don't wanna
you have like your one shot you know and
so yeah definitely that one you you and
uh uh Tom are great together Tom
obviously gave it his all I mean he
really just his all
um what was it actually like working
with him on I know it's a little generic
but what was it like working with
someone who's truly just giving
everything of himself to the role I
think it's a very beautiful thing to be
able to witness you know so many people
are going to be able to watch it and see
the outcome of what he did but to see it
in real time happening
um the care and the passion that he put
into it the the research the questioning
the
um the pondering back and forth
um I think
it's so special to be able to watch
someone create something and to be in
their craft and to be in the zone and um
I think he did a
truly wonderful job one of the things I
love learning about the behind the
scenes the making of things so is there
anything that you think like soon to be
fans of the series would be surprised to
learn about like the actual making of
the show
surprised I don't know I
I don't know but I think in general
the making of something is so
different and so much crazier than the
actual product itself it's like you know
what it takes to recreate a Rockefeller
scene in the 70s a simple walk down the
street the diner switching that up you
know like that already is just so many
people work so hard to be able to bring
that world
to now and um I just
everyone I think just did such a
wonderful job in the the paintings you
know having someone make these this
artwork that is Danny's artwork it's
just
every thought out thing is just you know
I have like mad respect for everyone who
who worked on that the last question for
you
um I'm actually pretty excited for the
Twister Twisters just because Leah's
directing it which is such an unusual I
never thought Lee would do it so what
was it about the script or story or was
it Lee that said oh I want to do this a
big part of it was Lee
um and and just kind of his his thoughts
on it and what he wanted to do with that
um and then also like I'm a huge fan of
Twister so to then be a part of this uh
sequel is like
easy like a bet let's do it you know so
and I really like my character so yeah
I'm excited actually this is my last
thing when you're playing a role like
Ariana is it one of these like how hard
is it for you to when you leave set to
like let go for the day and go back to
who you are and how much do you keep
some of Ariana like around during a
shoot so she's always close I think
um someone like Ariana I think I've
gotten better at stepping out of my
character sooner than I used to
um I also think my circumstances now
with my daughter and everything I can't
really afford to bring that energy to
her or to anyone else you know but I
still need to respect myself and say
that you need to come down period you
need to like
naturally de-stress yourself of this
character and just kind of shed her out
and so you know I'm a big fan of using
music to get into character and so
that's what I choose to do but it's I
feel would be dangerous to keep her
around me when I'm you know just by
myself or with my family and friends
um so I try to recognize it that's a
character and I don't need to put her
baggage on me every second of the day
and that note I gotta go I'm just gonna
say seriously congrats I wish you
nothing but the best thank you I
appreciate that